what's it mean to be here on the Oscars
red carpet for a nominated film this
this journey Jay got a haircut
come but you don't want to come and just
be
hanging on the wall you want to be in
you want to be a dance you want to dance
we get to be hopeful until the end of
the night so the very last card where is
TC we just knew he was gonna have his
behind here and he's not working it's
off doing TC things that make tctc
working while other people are playing
while other people are sleeping in the
movie industry one movie at a time
literally and saving the movie industry
where people are fret so wait a minute
if y'all win Jay you gonna go up and
ground you're gonna I'm storm in the
stage I'm grabbing the mic and don't let
us win
us win them
this way to do that right you just gonna
pan off they're gonna pan off as soon as
he runs off I actually think if they win
best pictures that you're gonna keep
these fellas off that soon no no no no
listen you know for us to just be here
is absolutely amazing if we're fortunate
enough to get our name called tonight
it's going to be a very loud group I'm
just gonna tell you right now yes we're
all here it's gonna be a very loud group
uh we all have our own way of
celebrating
um and it's you know
they're gonna definitely cut the
commercial from us they go it's gonna be
a hard cut okay now I do have to ask
because your boy Glenn Powell is
shooting another movie and now we've
seen him with no clothes on yeah what's
up what's
up I think he's a nudist at heart I
think Glenn might be a nudist at heart
sorry Glenn I think you have to ask his
dermatologist
well listen good luck tonight guys we
will say I can't well I hope y'all storm
the stage because I'll be like come on
let's go I need that foreign